in Philadelphia the smoke sits heavy
it's hanging and only moving slowly
across a vast part of the Northeastern
United States and this is where it's
been worst through the day at the city's
airport flights were paused for a few
hours visibility was so poor
and don't assume this is just Cloud were
it not for the smoke this would have
been a blue sky Day
within the city itself though it's
harder to see that the air is quite so
bad on Rocky's steps the city officials
advice to stay indoors had not filtered
through are you worried is it overly
concern you well we did look into
getting Mass the n95s this morning but
we're not that where it look actually
today looks better than yesterday even
though they said it's worse
um you know it's concerning you know
when you see the air is not clean all
the time but you know what are you going
to do about it you could either stop
your life stop what you're doing or you
know just deal with it so I'm being
careful they don't care so you're not
too worried sir I'm not worried I never
smoked for my life so I guess I'm
smoking a little bit but
the Striking thing is that you can smell
and feel the heaviness of smoke produced
by wildfires well over a thousand miles
to the north of here this is Central
Philadelphia where the air quality index
was well over 300 at one point that is
hazardous and it is record-breaking
at the city hall the health commissioner
live streamed her update spelling out
the dangers
well the scale
Philadelphia North through New Jersey
towards New York the smoke persists and
this staggering Manhattan time lapse
shows what New Yorkers have experienced
scientists have concluded it represents
the worst air pollution for America in
recent history the scale of the cause
the source is just staggering from
Canada's West Coast to its East Coast
forests are burning the country is set
for its worst year on record already and
we are far from being at the peak of the
season in British Columbia Donnie Creek
is the second largest fire in the
province's history covering the
equivalent of almost 450
000 football pitches and it's growing
prime minister Justin Trudeau has
welcomed President Biden's pledge to
send many more American firefighters
North to help but some fires will
probably burn through the summer in a
time where our climate seems to be
changing so fast this is yet another
hint that the consequences of extreme
weather events impact well beyond where
they hit Mark Stone Sky News in
Philadelphia